with them at the start of the season  they're on the court right now Parton  tried to draw a foul  he's yelling at Zach's orbit as they go  up the floor he's just waiting to give  him his teeth yep  Ferguson three-pointer that won't go and  here comes the technical foul didn't  want to stop the fast break down the  other end as soon as the rebound was  secured a technical foul for the first  time let's check in with Lisa Salters  hey Lisa hey Mike I was talking to  in the locker I mean it's it's right  across the arm and I'd see the pump  under the fist there's what got him he  was armored raising his hand to get  ready to call but waited for the whistle  to blow but I'm not sure he was yelling  at the correct official